the thesis coming from the left from
Elizabeth Warren here and all of the
panelists let me let me simplify it
because they mock the simplification of
the tax code they mock Americans who
like to simplify the language let me
simplify it first what are they really
saying we can't do anything don't ask us
we're just the taxpayer let's give all
the power to those in the executive
branch or the elected officials that'd
be without term limits that's really
what the thesis is from the left here
they're mocking the mere idea that
people could be in office that one could
govern in a way that would be simple
that would be effective really the basis
of our entire government if you actually
think about it it was set up with three
different branches in order to mitigate
one another's power and it was set up to
be unbelievably simple so that it
wouldn't be screwed up by the
establishment by the career politicians
that you now see in DC of course which
we tried to flee in England first let's
just start off with some of their claims
and the spirit of what they're doing
here and I'm not defending Donald
Trump's tax plan I want to be clear
about that I'm not defending his tax
plan because well you can't really
defend it it's not really been released
in detail but the attacks that they're
making their macro attacks on the
principles of Donald Trump's tax plans
the first example is opposed Warren
rightaway claims to make her case just
to the worst example that there was no
growth in the economy tanked under
Reagan I think go and that happened
across the board
it happened Americans participated the
pie got bigger we all got a little more
to eat 1980 what happens then
Ronald Reagan deregulation fire the cops
on Wall Street and the big one cut taxes
for those at the top and then invest
less in education in infrastructure in
basic research I love it I skip from the
New Deal to Reagan what happened between
there and if I just say it I hope nobody
really yeah the economy tanked under
Reagan the word yuppie was invented when
Reagan was president it was meant to
describe middle class people upper
middle class people who had very
well-paying jobs you would be
hard-pressed to find any piece of
Americana in media that would treat the
80s as anything other than an economic
booms known it's known as the era of
excess and cocaine and wealth and
supernatural employment levels by the
way everyone did well under Reagan if
you look at the charts here's something
that's important this is kind of in
their in their their their deck of
tricks as they try and say well you know
the middle-class tanked what are they
really trying to say they're trying to
say that the gap between the middle
class and the wealthy got wider that's
what your Bernie Sanders saying right
now wealthiest 1% okay but the middle
class were still doing better overall
matter of fact as upper level incomes go
up so do middle incomes and lower
incomes we know that for a fact and this
is what they do what they want to do is
play on your own selfish nature they
want to play on the most debased human
selfish instinct which is covetousness
jealousy let's say you have 20% of a pie
that's worth $10 okay now that pie grows
because of the other 80% okay
that pie is now worth 10 million dollars
and you have 5% where are you better off
are you concerned about your slice of
the pie or are you grateful that you're
better off are you re saying you know
what well I'm a man I'm amazed as to how
much better I'm doing now if you're
focused on what someone else has that
you don't have you're never going to be
happy and that's what's required for the
Democratic Party I heard this once I
don't know who said it
someone said creative people don't get
jealous they get inspired I would
actually expand that to successful
people almost all successful people they
don't get jealous they get inspired
something else they don't talk about the
Laffer curve this is something that was
actually sort of learned and coined
under Reagan what does it mean there are
different laugher curves for different
countries you can see that graph it
basically means that there is a point
where maximal revenue is generated and
when you start increasing taxable income
that revenue goes down or again let's
say for example if that peak occurs
around 40% that's where you get the most
amount of revenue and let's say if you
do increase overall income taxes on the
highest 10% of earners to 70 percent you
get a 10% increase in taxes
which is actually typically what you see
mr. Carter yeah Carter then it says okay
is it worth it to increase that text
from 40% to 70% to only see a 10 percent
increase in revenue that's what the
concept is behind the Laffer curve
something else Hauser's law you've heard
us talk about this houses law basically
states the idea that you're never going
to have more than 19 to 20 percent
despite what the income tax brackets are
in other words doesn't matter how much
you tax that revenue almost always
equals to somewhere in that 19 to 20
percent range let's widen it say 18 to
22 percent that's still if you're taxing
someone 30 percent or 70 percent it's
called how there's low now here's the
thing I understand some economist will
disagree with it we'll have some people
out there saying well this has long
since been debunked first off it hasn't
there are still plenty of brilliant
economists some of the most brilliant
economists in the world who actually
still teach these concepts even an Ivy
League colleges but let's give you that
and say okay it's still being debated
Elizabeth Warren's book the panel here
in Bill Maher's show acts as though
again it's just settled it's settled
economics none of those things apply
let's just increase tax taxes let's
increase the tax brackets and things
will be solved they don't even allow for
the idea that hey maybe someone isn't
stupid maybe they just understand
different points of economics than you
do the one-page thing they had a hundred
days what happened during the first 99
and a half days they mocked this as
though simple as bad misses our one-page
of can you believe it
yeah sure might we'll be simpler it
would be a paragraph what you know and
that's what occurred for a long time
throughout human history because we
believe that a flat percentage rate was
what was fair because if you make ten
thousand dollars you pay a thousand if
you make hundred thousand dollars you
pay ten thousand that actually seems
fair but they mock it as though simple
is wrong and this is why I don't
actually believe I always say I'm not a
centrist and I don't believe in finding
common ground because let's say I'm all
the way over here well my right your
left so okay you're right let's say I'm
all the way over here on the right okay
one page a one-page tax code let's say
there's someone all the way over here
you're left again we're going with
you're here because I'm concerned about
the viewer looking out for the photos so
I'm here one page they're here well the
current tax code is over 70,000 pages so
if you find him
middle ground I'm at one there that's
still 35,000 pages I don't want to find
that middle ground you have a group of
people who have no idea how to govern
they don't understand public policy they
don't understand how this country
interacts with the rest of the world
there are people that have never held
these jobs who most from the for the
most part want to destroy the very
agencies that they're that they're
representing sign them up he said like
it's a bad thing yes you're having
people in office who don't believe that
they should suckle at the government
teat forever like Joe Biden like John
McCain yachty Sanders said I want to
hire the person who doesn't want the job
here's something we act as though all
these people they have no experience
governing you know didn't George
Washington George Washington's biggest
experience in governing was flipping the
bird to the previous government that he
left to create the greatest country and
you think George Washington would have
been mocked by today's left for no
qualifications for his his wooden grill
and he walked away from office George
Washington is one of the few example
doesn't let me love him as a leader he's
one of the few people in power
throughout the history of mankind to
willingly walk away because he
understood the temptation he was a no no
no listen
you don't want me in there that one
people were begging and pleading with
him to stay George Washington was a
great example was a great example of
leadership as someone who's revered
because of precisely that quality but
people like Carl Reiner people like Bill
Maher cannot fathom someone like a
George Washington today someone who
would actually go into a role in
government not wanting to selfishly grow
their own role in government that's a
beautiful thing to me I don't see how
I'm the only one who gets it next clip
simplify our burdensome tax code as if
the Americans can't distinguish between
three and seven like oh you talk about
the tax break yeah it's just so out no
no it's not really can't distinguish
between three and seven it's that the
average American despite I know you want
to make it selling maybe they're stupid
if they voted for Donald Trump is
the average American including brilliant
Americans can't necessarily decipher a
70,000 Plus page tax code it's at the
average of it some of the average
American can't decipher between 3 and 7
it's that they actually can't decipher
the tax code that's so complicated they
have to hire accountants and H&R Block
to keep up by the way to sustain the
employment of entire wings of government
that stay subsequently open because the
taxpayer dollars it's that they can't
really understand exactly what the
loopholes are which is why people are
paid six-figure huge incomes just to
figure that out and it's why people fear
being audited on average more than being
mugged in the United States I would even
say that we could discuss having a flat
tax or no weight flat tax is another
giant giveaway to the rich people why do
you want to do that I love again this is
this is the change of words giveaway
said that's the flat tax is a big
giveaway to the rich which may seem
confusing to people who typically
understand words to me what they
actually mean this is where we have to
go back to the socialist lexicon where
the word giveaway as a matter of fact
means not stealing money already earned
oh I see what that makes so in other
words everything if you weren't $100 and
I just take $50 at gunpoint okay and
then tomorrow I come in and say you know
what today I'm only gonna take $40 of
your 100 at gunpoint call me Ed McMahon
because I just gave away a huge job we
do not have a tax revenue problem we do
we have record tax revenues in this
country we have over well I think one
point zero eight trillion collected in
the first quarter of 2017 over one point
zero eight trillion collected record tax
revenues that are being collected but if
you taxed every single dollar earned in
this country over a million dollars
every dollar over a million dollars at
100% you still would not have enough
it's not a revenue problem we can
continue and I know some people say
that's hypocritical because he talked
about the Laffer curve I'm not just
talking about income tax we have so many
sources of tax revenue now a health care
mandate tax another energy tax they're
hidden everywhere there is more tax
revenue than ever and our debts
ballooning out of control our deficit is
still out of control because we have a
spending problem and this is my
Donald Trump - I haven't seen enough
spending cuts this is something that's
immensely unpopular with people in
office because they promise a bunch of
free crap then they get into office and
they realize hole in a second at some
point someone's going to have to pay for
this and any time you've given someone a
free lunch you can't pull it away let's
assume for a second that under Reagan
the economy tanked Elizabeth Warren
tried to imply okay let's assume that
tax revenues always went up it went up
in a linear equation if you started
taxing the wealthy at 70% let's assume
what the wealthy wouldn't leave this
country and go somewhere else if you tax
them over 50% let's assume for a second
that we were actually raising enough
revenue through taxes lets us none of
it's true but let's assume in all of
their math is correct okay it still
wouldn't change the moral
reprehensibility of continued thievery
if I go into your house right now and I
steal your TV and your jewelry and your
cash and I go when I give it to a
homeless shelter or I give it to
Salvation Army that's nice but I still
stole your sheep hey if you like this
clip it's taken from the full daily show
available exclusively at lotto with
credit com / mug club that's for mug
club members because we can't be
dependent here in the Google YouTube
overlords subscribe there we have a
daily show full hour every day if you
don't well there's no saving you